dans la commune voisine à elancourt
trois candidats pour le poste de maire
on reçoit l'un d'entre eux sur ce
plateau michel rossi vont soir dans ça
vous êtes la tête de liste et l'encours
c'est vous une liste citoyenne ouverte
qui a été investi par la république en
marche comment se déroule votre campagne
à 12 jours de ce scrutin est ce qu'elle
se poursuit à elancourt cette campagne
absolument
alors déjà si vous le permettez je vais
dire quelques mots pour présenter les
personnes qui sont sur cette liste
donc sur 35 candidats nous avons plus
d'une trentaine de personnes qui sont
sans aucune appartenance politique
d'où l'appellation de liste citoyenne
même si en ce qui me concerne j'ai été
investir dans tête de 10 par la
république en marge
nous ne sommes que quelques personnes à
relever de ce mouvement et donc il était
normal que nous respections la majorité
des membres de notre liste et leur
tendance sans étiquette politique
d'ailleurs je crois que monsieur
fourgous a précisé qu'il avait lui-même
quelques personnes de la république en
marche sur sa liste madame perrotta ne
l'a pas fait mais je crois qu'elle a
également des personnes en marche sur sa
liste donc c'est une liste investie par
la république en marche comme c'est
inscrit actuellement sur votre écran
mais qui est bien citoyennes ouvertes
pluriel vous venez vous du monde
associatif
pourquoi vous vous lancez dans cette
campagne justement vous êtes lancée
puisque la campagne a déjà démarré
mais vous êtes lancés dans cette
campagne des municipales alors j'avais
également des responsabilités
associatives mais en fait je viens du
secteur privé j'ai fait toute ma
carrière dans le secteur privé dans les
ressources humaines
que ce soit dans la métallurgie un
grande distribution les assurances ou le
secteur bancaire et j'ai travaillé aussi
bien sur l'aspect formation
apprentissage que négociation sociale
développement des compétences ou gestion
du budget et donc du coup pourquoi
vouloir vous engagez cabinet long cours
parce que depuis à peu près un an je
suis à la retraite et je me rends compte
que cette ville devient malheureusement
une ville dortoir qu'il y a beaucoup
d'atouts mais qui ne sont pas mises en
avant et ayant effectivement l'esprit
solidaire et m'intéressant aux personnes
j'ai choisi avec d'autres de m'engager
pour ma ville
m montants disponibles à disposition de
cette ville juste une pression sur
ville-dortoir on sait qu'elle en cours
il ya quand même de grands groupes
installés
je pense à à thales à airbus pourquoi je
vous parlais de ville dortoir si
justement parce que la plupart des
personnes que vous interrogez quand vous
les rencontrez 10 bat jeux partout le
matin tout le monde ne travaille pas sur
place malheureusement beaucoup viennent
d'ailleurs y compris d'ailleurs danser
dans ces grands groupes et donc par tôt
le matin reconnaît ses difficultés de
circulation y rentre tard le soir et le
week-end quand on est déjà bien occupé
dans la semaine on n'a pas eu le temps
de profiter de sa vie de mal aux enjeux
sont dites est être allé à la rencontre
des élans courtois d'ailleurs je crois
qu'avant de constituer votre programme
c'est depuis octobre vous menez des
rencontres auprès des élans courtois
pour recueillir des deux bonnes idées
afin de constituer ce programme était
censé un programme co construit suite à
ces premiers échanges
nous avons commencé à nous rendre compte
des axes essentiels pour pour il encourt
que ce soit de redynamiser cette ville
parce que vraiment elle a perdu toute
attractivité elle perd régulièrement des
habitants depuis 2006 c'est également
une ville où il ya des instances et des
institutions culturelles sportives mais
qui ne sont pas ouvertes à tous et
accessible à tous notamment aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
donc il y a des choses à faire aussi sur
le plan culture et sport c'est une ville
je ne vous parlerai pas de la zone des 4
as mais qui n'est pas très reluisante
ce sujet vous souhaitez voir un
écoquartier tout à fait absolument c'est
un de nos axes forts sur l'attractivité
et relancer le dynamisme économique dans
cette ville
donc nous avons pour cela appartement
vous lancez un écoquartier vous pouvez
bénéficier de subventions donc ça ne
pénalisera absolument pas les impôts des
élans courtois ou bénéficier de
subventions à la fois gouvernementaux et
également de gouvernementales et de
subventions de la région également pour
construire cet écoquartier nous enfuir
on nous enfouir les lignes électriques
promesse de monsieur fourgous depuis
plus d'une dizaine d'années mais qui n'a
toujours pas été tenues messieurs avant
de
ces décisions si vous êtes élu est-ce
qu'il y aura une consultation des élans
content c'est que c'est l'un des trois
axes de votre campagne
aller vers plus de démocratie
participative c'est fait nous allons
d'ailleurs dans une de nos propositions
je vous la livre en avant-première
nommer un adjoint à la démocratie
participative pour d'une part quand il
ya un projet fortement impactant un
quartier associer tous les acteurs
concernés donc nous travaillons non
seulement avec les habitants mais
également avec les commerçants que nous
souhaitons c'est aussi une zone de
commerces qui bien entendu ne met pas en
concurrence les commerces déjà existants
donc nous aurons effectivement cette
concertation nous aurons également cet
adjoint qui prendra régulièrement
contact avec des référentes quartier
pour bien remonté tous les besoins des
quartiers et nous ouvrirons également un
service à la mairie qui s'appellera
relation citoyen alors le deuxième axe
redynamiser la ville vous en avez déjà
dit un mot il ya une aussi une
thématique qui revient largement dans
cette campagne des municipales c'est
l'écologie et c'est le troisième axe
aussi de votre campagne qu'est ce que
vous prévoyez en termes d'effets
d'écologie c'est un axe très fort dans
notre campagne
vous aurez la possibilité de valoriser
tout ce qui est espaces verts nous avons
un peu près 100 110 hectares d'espacés
verts dans cette commune nous souhaitons
non seulement bien sûr les préserver or
il faut savoir que monsieur fourgous à
installer un certain nombre de logements
le stade paul nicholas on a d'ailleurs
fait les frais vous avez quand même
inscrit à saint quentin
une construction de logements de plus de
850 habitations je ne sais pas où elles
se trouveront mais cela pose question et
je crois savoir également que france
miniature dont le contrat arrive à
échéance en 2026 n'a pas eu de garanties
la prolongement de prolongement de ce
contrat donc si el haouès du stade paul
nicholas vous avez vu fleurir quelques
maisons à la place de france miniature
vous pouvez vous attendre à une environ
800 ou 900 logements
donc c'est pas du tout ce qu'on souhaite
nous on souhaite conserver france
miniature et développer un partenariat
justement avec les écoles pour
développer tout l'aspect histoire
géographique qui est tout à fait
possible avec ce parc est un autre
projet d'envergure je voudrais vous
entendre sur ce sujet l'aménagement de
la colline d'elancourt en vue de ces jo
de 2024 et ce qu'il faut repenser à
l'avenir de cette colline est ce que le
projet qui est prévu vous satisfait ce
que vous imaginez un autre futur pour
cette colline d'ailleurs déjà le projet
prévu j'aimerais qu'on le précise parce
que feue la piste de ski ça c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
l'idée d'un globe ou d'un restaurant
panoramique ou sommet me semble
totalement surréaliste ça ne répond
absolument pas aux attentes des élans
courtois c'est totalement indépendant
d'en faire une zone olympique
donc nous nous sommes pour les jeux
olympiques puisque nous sommes pour
l'attractivité de notre territoire
mais cela veut dire des jeux olympiques
éco-responsable comme s'est engagé le
comité des jeux olympiques
et ça veut dire un aménagement famille
et au sommet auront éventuellement une
table d'orientation mais pas une
construction pérenne en dur
merci michel rossi je rappelle que vous
êtes la tête de liste des longs cours
c'est vous et je précise que sont
également candidats à elancourt
catherine b rotor faste avec réinventons
elancourt et jean michel fourgous avec
aller elancourt